[Music]
Brian Cornell CEO of target welcome to
Stanford into systems leadership it is
great to be here Brian tell us a little
bit about the recent successes of target
at a time when retail has been
struggling you've had a good run the
last six to twelve months what's made
that possible well it's really a
combination of a number of things that
we've been working on for several years
now and if I go back to February of 2017
we laid out a have a three-year vision
for the company we said we're going to
invest billions of dollars at that point
I said seven billion dollars over a
three year period to invest in
reimagining our stores in building new
smaller stores and urban centers and on
college campuses reinvest in our brands
invest in technology and fulfillment
capabilities and make a big investment
in our people and the success we're
seeing right now is really a combination
of all those elements starting to mature
or executing at scale and they're all
starting to work together that's driving
for us great top-line growth market
share gains and importantly more traffic
in our stores and visits to our site so
let's talk about that how do you
envision the customer experience over
the next five to ten years and that
blend between digital and physical yeah
I actually think blend is the right term
and I think from a consumer standpoint
they've really lost sight of whether
they're shopping in a physical
environment or a digital environment in
most cases their shopping starts with
that mobile phone in their hands that
digital device and it's how they decide
where they're gonna shop what they're
looking for if you want one of our
Target stores this afternoon I guarantee
you we'd find consumers with a phone in
their hand they'd be looking at their
latest Pinterest they'd be checking
things on their favorite digital site
they'd have their shopping list there so
that device really guides them through
the shopping experience so I think more
and more there's a blurring and a
blending that's taking place and it's a
combination of both and I think the
consumer today is enjoying the fact that
shoppings become really easy they get
the best of both they get a physical
experience when they want it well they
don't have time they can shop in their
desk or from their classroom where kids
are never on their phones let's hope out
but they're constantly in touch
and we've made it really easy now for
them to interface with our brand on
their own terms
so target has a very large presence here
in the valley you have many many data
scientists and data analytics tell us a
little bit about how you thought about
building that competency inside of the
organization and having such a large
presence here in Silicon Valley so we
drop back several years ago and started
thinking about building the target of
the future
it really started with an investment in
understanding the consumer and really
understanding what they were looking for
and how do we build the capabilities
starting with data science to really
guide us through that journey so well I
can talk a lot about strategy the other
thing that we've recognized is how
important it is to have the right
capabilities in place and whether that's
technology or supply chain capabilities
for us product design our focus on
execution at store level but data and
analytics has been an important
guideposts for us as we've gone through
this journey it's hard to recruit people
in this area when you there may not be
familiar with all of the capabilities
the target has or what's that been like
well we've been fortunate we've
recruited quite a few Stanford grads and
I think what's attracting them to our
business is the richness of our data the
fact that on an average week we get 30
million consumers shopping our stores a
similar number going to target comm so
we have all this rich data and we
understand where consumers are shopping
what they're looking for and I think
they've been really tricked by the
ability to take that data and help us
build a future you've been in the retail
business that grocery business the CPG
business for the last 20 plus years what
are the biggest changes you've seen and
how do you imagine things continue to
evolve over the next decade well I've
certainly seen this trend towards
personalization and localization and if
I think about the changes in consumer
packaged goods in some cases those big
brands that you and I grew up with well
they've been replaced by smaller local
niche brands brands that we didn't see
when we grew up and they're being
regionalised across the country so I
think the consumer today is looking for
that unique personalized experience
whether they're shopping a Target store
or they're walking through a local store
right here on the state
for campus cause you think about your
time as the CEO what's been the biggest
surprised that you didn't expect that
you look back on and say hi I had no
idea that was coming yeah I think I
walked in recognizing the importance of
a clear strategy for an organization but
I've come to realize just how important
culture is a clear purpose and
importantly as I said before ensuring
that that strategy is supported by great
couple capabilities and the importance
of team if you and I are sitting here in
2029 doing this interview again what do
you think's target will stand for for
your customers at that moment in time
yeah I think we'll still be true to the
purpose we have today and its really
focused on bringing a little bit of joy
to all the families we serve each and
every week you know and really enhancing
their everyday life so I think that
focus on families that connection we
have today with moms with kids with
families across the country I think
it'll be as true in the future as it is
today Brian Cornell CEO of Target
welcome to Stanford and thank you so
much great to be here thanks
[Music]
you